the latest addition to the xbox one
backwards compatibility program word
puzzle yep you heard that right might
not have been the xbox 360 game you were
looking for but it looks like some
better options are on the way I'm Lucy
and welcome to your still no mass effect
two really gamespot news update on
Twitter someone asked Xbox boss try
saying that three times fast Phil
Spencer if there was a reason why there
aren't more high-profile games being
added to the catalog lately he explained
that it comes down to the order of
things as titles come out of testing
more intriguingly he teased we have some
I've been really looking forward to
coming soon 25 most requested games for
the backwards compatibility program
currently on the Xbox feedback site I'll
call of duty black ops 2 field Scrolls 5
skyrim call of duty modern warfare 2
call of duty 4 modern warfare and call
of duty modern warfare 3 i'm sensing a
theme each of them has more than a
hundred thousand boats despite the clear
interest there's no guarantee that any
of them will ever come to the program on
the spencers comment is in reference to
any of those games games are added to
the backwards compatibility program
whenever they are ready not on a set
schedule games confirmed for the catalog
but not yet released include skate 3
bioshock bioshock two and bioshock
infinite even though bioshock the
collection just came out so which games
would you like to see added let me know
in the comments below i'll come find me
on Twitter I'm at Lucy James games the
more on xbox make sure you keep it games
[ __ ]
you